so uh welcome to uh pi data global
marching
um our channel will be discussing today
deep neural deduplication
uh
ai architect with over 10 years of
experience in various machine learning
projects including nlp and computer
vision
so i'll hand it over to you
thank you very much uh okay welcome
everyone hello guys uh today i would
like to tell you uh about deep neural
duplication so basically the talk is
how our team
has leveraged deep neural networks
and contrastive learning to
handle a large-scale duplication problem
the talk will be organized in the
following way at first i would like to
tell a little bit on the business case
to clearly explain the need for the
duplication
next i will provide a brief introduction
to contrastive learning and then move to
the description of our solution
explain how we scale it up and present
the results and the next steps that we
plan to perform
uh so let's start
let's try and move the
marcian could i just ask whether you
would want questions during the
presentation or during the last five
minutes i would prefer them at the very
end because i believe that some of the
questions uh that might appear
immediately might be answered by the uh
later slides so let's keep them uh for
the end of the presentation thank you
thanks
yep so so uh let's start with the
business case
uh one of our clients is a company
called dodge data and analytics and what
they do is they fetch construction
related articles
from all over the internet
so that they are the first to know of
new beats and opportunities and what
they do is they further share this
information with the clients that are
construction firms
as they collect the data from multiple
different data sources
some duplicates may appear
for example two different web pages may
use varying words different or
incomplete data fields but still refer
to the same construction project so to
prevent dodge customers from being
presented the same information multiple
times
and offer highest possible data quality
there is a need for an effective the
duplication mechanism
till now does been using a rule-based
heuristic to produce a duplicate
candidate for each new record however
it's very very very hard
to capture all aspects of what makes a
duplicate with a handcrafted algorithm
hence such an algorithm was not quite
accurate and the results were further
evaluated by data stewards
the data stewards in parallel uh used to
spend a meaningful amount of time
on identifying the duplicates manually
so
that was very time consuming and
error-prone process and therefore it
required replacement
however
this process
has been in place for a long time
so there is a large data set of
identified duplicates available
the data set consists of several
millions of records collected over the
years and each record has already
assigned duplicate if such duplicate
exists
a record is simply
a dictionary of named entities uh
extracted from pretext articles and
there is a variety of them uh covering
different aspects of constructive
construction projects
such as locations dates amounts titles
names and and so on overall there are
several dozens of them
and we can distinguish two types of
named entities
text named entities like project title
or owner name and numeric named entities
like for example total square feet
latitude longitudes of the project's
location and and so on
us
we
got access to a huge label data set we
could think of applying a supervised
machine learning for the duplication
problem
for example we could consider building a
binary classifier that takes as an input
a pair of records and tells if they
constitute a duplicate or not
however
this solution wouldn't
scale up
because for each new record
we would require pairing kits with all
the other millions of freakers in the
database
and then running such a huge
data set of pairs through our classifier
and that would be definitely two-time
resource consuming
bestly if you could
if we could simply transform the records
into some points on a
hyperplane and
then measure the distance between those
points with an ordinary distance metric
that is easy to compute
like for example euclidean distance and
uh ideally if the distances would
indicate the similarity like small
distances would indicate that there is a
large similarity and large distances
would indicate that the similarity is
small so in some circumstances we could
simply project each new record onto the
plane and just look in a small
neighborhood to find is if there is
something if there is
we got to duplicate so to sum up ideally
if we could try to if you could if we
could learn
such an embedding space where
similar examples are grouped together
and far away from the similar ones
and that's exactly what we can achieve
with the help of contrastive learning
i believe that the idea of contrastive
learning
uh
comes from 2005 but to be absolutely
honest with you
uh i i really got into it after reading
the paper face nets
from 2015
and
even if this paper is already
6 years old
it nicely introduces
many ideas and covers many aspects
also applicable by more
modern meters so i will start with
describing it over here
face net
introduces a loss function called tree
blood loss and as its name suggests
triplet laws take three kinds of
examples encore positive and negative
so
given an encore example we try to find
another example belonging to the same
class as encore and we call it positive
and an example of a different class than
the negative
and the anchor sorry and we call it a
negative
and what we try to do with the help of
triplet laws we try to satisfy this
equation
what means we try to make the distance
between the representation of the anchor
and the representation of the positive
smaller
than the distance between the encore and
the negative and this might be converted
to the following optimization problem
however in this form
our model could easily find a trivial
solution
what i mean is our model could simply
transform all the input records into the
same point into the same representation
so that this distance
so that the distance between them is
always zeroed
and this criteria is always satisfied
but that's not the goal we try to
achieve
uh
to prevent from finding this trivial
solution we add an extra parameter
parameter
margin
and this margin parameter
and forces that the positives are
located closer than the n chord than the
negative by at least this margin value
and this is the ultimate form of the
free blood loss
in practice
triplet loss uh is usually
uh is usually used on uh on a mini batch
level so
given a batch of samples uh we run them
through a neural network and we obtain a
batch of embeddings a bunch of
representation
and then among those embeddings we
select the three plates and add the t3
plates to the triplet loss
the question that may appear here is how
to select the triplets
the most straightforward approach would
be to simply generate all triplets from
the mini batch and run them to the
to the triplets
however first of all it would produce
many many candidates and most of them
would be pretty useless because the
criteria from the
triplet loss would be already satisfied
because the
negatives would be already located
further away
from the positive and further away by at
least this distance value so
in such case the loss for such examples
would be zero and this examples wouldn't
contribute to the
training of the model
what is more interesting are heart
negatives and semi-heart negatives heart
negatives are negatives that are located
closer to the anchor than the positive
and semi-heart negatives are negatives
that are in between heart negatives and
easy negatives
it means that they are
further away than the positive
but not further away than this margin
distance value
so knowing what we are looking for we
could simply average the loss over all
hard and semi-hard triplets and this
kind of approach is called batch hole
alternatively uh we could select the
hardest positive and the hardest
negative for each anchor and this
strategy is called batch card
it's hard to answer which of them work
best in practice
because it depends on the task and
basically if you could try both of them
okay
so far it may seem like
contrastive learning might be applied
only in the supervised setting
because we need to know the labels to
create positive and negative parts
but this is luckily not true and we may
apply contrastive learning also in the
unsupervised setting for example we
could follow the framework presented in
this paper from 2020
where the authors suggest to use
augmentation what they say is that given
an example x
we can randomly select some augmentation
methods and apply to x what results in
example
x i
uh we can
do it once again and come up with an
example xj and us x i and xj are
basically the same example because they
are just slightly modified version of x
we would like to make the representation
similar
and this might be achieved uh with the
help of normalized cross-entropy so
given a positive pair of representation
that i and the j that corresponds to x i
and x j that are just the altered
version of x so we would like to make
those uh similar
uh especially we would like to make it
uh more similar to each other than that
i and that k
where k are all the other examples
within the same batch so this is the
positive pair and this is the negative
part and the final loss is computed
among all positive pairs in the minibar
so this way we can apply contrastive
learning in the unsupervised setting
i just presented two approaches one
supervised
and one unsupervised but there is way
way more to learn
however that i believe that at this
moment
all of you should have a good
understanding
of the basic concepts
that will allow you to fully understand
the methods that we created internally
in sci
so our solution let's take a look
if you remember i mentioned that we had
two kinds of entities text entities
and numeric entities so we decided to
tackle the problem in the two stages
approach
and build two separate models
at first we focus only on the text
entities and we used expert pro sentence
transformers package this is basically
uh word for text similarity
and we train it in the flowing way
we took all
text name entities and concatenated them
into a consistent block of text we just
separate the named entities by the sap
token that that is used by
bert tokenizer to distinguish between uh
between sentences uh and then we use the
batch heart and triplet laws to train
this model uh however we uh we added a
few modifications and the most
meaningful one is
we modified the way we generate the
batches
because we dealt with millions of data
records and a single record usually had
no more than just few duplicates it was
extremely unlikely that two duplicates
would land in the same batch even if we
used
large bar sizes
so we modified the sampling method in
such a way that for each anchor there is
always a single positive example at
hence we sample we batch heart only
only the negatives
in the next step
we moved towards the numeric features
and here we simply run them through a
few layers a piece forward network
with non-linearity
and then concatenate the result
with the result produced by expert for
the text features and
we run
triplet loss on such concatenated
vectors however in this case we use
asbert only as a feature extractor and
we don't back propagate the gradients
through it
we hope that this way
we could explicitly teach the fit for
what network how to extend the vectors
produced by s bird uh with this extra
information contained in the
numeric
fields
for inference we simply run a new record
from both of our models we concatenate
the
the results to obtain this concatenate
and binding vectors and we are ready to
compare
this vector with all the other records
in the database
using a simple similarity metric in our
case it's a cosine
similarity however this still doesn't
scale up because we still need to
compare this data regard to all the
other records uh in the database so
let's see let's see uh what we did
uh basically
to identify like the nearest neighbors
like i previously mentioned that if we
project the record onto the plane we
look in some smaller neighborhood
so to identify the neighbor's networks
we
could perform an exhaustive search
however the complexity of such
exhaustive search is n times d
which means uh where n stands for the
number of records in the database and d
is the the dimensionality uh of the
of the vectors
and as you can see we had quite a lot of
data records because at the moment of
starting the project there was 4.5
millions of data points and this number
is still growing and also the
resultant dimensionality of our
concatenated vectors is nearly
800 dimensions so at first we wanted to
reduce
the search space and not to compare
against all n records in the database
but just some subset and to achieve that
we could use approximate nearest
neighbor search
for example we could try to select
two points from our embedding space
and run a cup and and
run a hyperplane
through them
and in the next step try to separate the
remaining points according to the side
of the plane they are located on and
performing this iteratively
would actually
built a binary tree
a binary search tree in in such a tree
uh the nodes represent the splits
and the leaves represent the data points
actually we could even build multiple
such trees and run this search in
parallel to get uh further performances
gain
uh and this is not really our idea this
idea comes from annoy and as you can see
we can reduce the
number of comparisons logarithmically
because this is uh the
uh the average
height of the
uh of the binary tree so instead of
running and comparisons we could run
we could just perform
log n comparisons but i know it's not
the only library there is more there's
space there is flounders falcon
they implement different algorithms like
locality sensitive hashing like grab
traversals and among graph travelers so
there's a very popular and powerful
method called hierarchical navigable
small words so
i encourage you to take a look
however
in our case we didn't rely on any of the
approximate nearest neighbors
approaches
first of all
elasticsearch supports a k-nearest
neighbor search it is implemented as an
exhaustive search and it allows to
perform it on the uh embeddings
but what's the most important for us is
that it also supports an efficient
metadata filtering
uh
it simply means that we can
limit the search space by some criterias
and for us it's rather unlikely that a
newly published record uh will be a
duplicate of something like published
like i don't know five years ago so we
just limit
the results to the records published in
a certain time range and perform
the search among them
this second case
reducing the dimensionality
well this could be handled with
dimensionality reduction techniques like
pca for example or simply learning for
smaller embeddings and actually
in one of the next steps that we try to
perform we aim
for the second option because we find it
simply more elegant what are the results
okay so at first we determined that the
candidates produced by the previous
rule-based heuristic
they were selected by the data stewards
only in 43 of the cases and the rest of
duplicates
was identified fully manually
however we believe that still there
might be many duplicates never found by
the previous approach because when we
evaluate the predictions made by our
solution
we can see that in some cases
the
predictions are considered as incorrect
even if they look exactly the same
or nearly the same as the input record
so we decided to still keep human in the
loop approach to enhance this data
quality
by asking the data stewards to identify
previously not found duplicates
and we want to present them top 10
results and ask them to identify
duplicates among them
hence we use top 10 accuracy to express
how many times a duplicate will be found
for a record known to have a duplicate
among top 10 predictions of the model
and as we can see
using just the text features brought us
to the level of nearly 75 percent of top
10 accuracy and
adding the other features uh added
an extra 10 points so this is a huge
gain in comparison to the
previous
algorithm even if we still keep the
human look
human in the loop approach and we
believe that this is just the lower
boundary of the performance for the
reasons that i mentioned
in the beginning of the slides so what
are the next steps
as i mentioned uh previously we want to
enhance the data quality uh before we
move to a fully automated approach
however as some of the duplicates are
not identified it also affects the
convergence of our model so we want to
run our solution in production for a few
months and then collect the data we hope
this
the data quality will improve with the
help of our model and we will
try to retrain our model
in parallel we are working on improving
the current ner solution
by applying some state-of-the-art
methods and we also want to add more
types of named entities to capture wider
scope of the
project
and then we also want to
shrink the size of the embedding vectors
that we produce but this is something
you already know
and ultimately we would like to train
everything uh in an end-to-end manner uh
to create a consistent framework for
the duplication okay guys so
let's let's try to summarize uh what i
what i said today um
at first i would like you to remember
and and take away from this conversation
that this presentation that contrastive
learning is a representation learning
technique that learns such an embedding
space where similar records are located
near each other and kept far away from
the dissimilar ones and this kind of
representation is super useful for
information retrieval problems such as
the duplication for example or for
example for semantic search
and obtaining this kind of
representation might be achieved both in
supervised and unsupervised setting
to perform efficient search among such
embeddings you need to consider two
factors the first one is the number of
records that you are
about to search among and the second one
is the dimensionality of your vectors
to reduce the search space you can apply
approximate nearest neighbor search but
as you could see from our example it's
not always necessary because sometimes
you can incorporate like the domain
knowledge to reduce the search space
and
selecting the right approximate nearest
neighbor method
depends on your task
and should be performed wisely uh you
should be before before selecting the
approximate nearest neighbor search
method you need to answer yourself a few
questions like how much ram do i have am
i just about to perform this search or
also add new examples frequently uh but
that seems like a good topic for a
separate talk so i will just finish here
thank you very much are there any
questions
there are quite a few here uh marchand
so thank you very much for for the very
interesting talk um there
the same question looks like was asked
by somebody in both the q a as well as
the chat it
is it easy to calculate if triplet easy
semi
slash hard what should i do
if i want to construct only semi-hard
triplets for training
uh what so the question is what you
should what you should do to construct
just the semi-triplets for training
right
sounds like it yes
uh okay so uh basically uh you should
perform this operation on the mini batch
level uh
for multiple reasons
uh and uh
it's it's basically uh just simple
because uh
in most of the cases uh you need to go
to do like the exhaustive search once
again so it means like compare
all records against all the other
records by some kind of similarity
matrix and then you can simply select uh
what's uh being considered as a
semi-hard example
uh in your case
however when i'm thinking about it uh
you could also try like more
sophisticated approaches especially when
you deal with like
large batches and you need to search
effectively but normally uh what i think
is done in most of the cases and what we
also did is just calculating the
similarity matrix and then selecting the
triplets that meet the semi-heart
condition
great there's it was a question by leave
but i think it was answered in one of
your slides uh there's a question by
stefan
here oh sorry he's just posting a link
to something with regard to a n uh
there's a question by jorge can you
explain again who were the final
customers uh why did they need the
deduplicated records uh he missed the
context for the initial problem
okay uh so basically uh our one of our
customers is a company
uh that operates on the construction
market and it's like a middle layer
between the construction firm and the
projects
uh however if for example
you want to get some information uh
dedicated to your specialization like
you are a sink mounting company and you
would like to be interested only in
projects that require mounting for
example four sinks and only from
california and florida uh you can tell
dodge please provide me with this
information as soon
as you get something
however this kind of information might
be presented in multiple places so
you as a user you probably don't want to
be bothered like i don't know 10 times
with the same information so that's why
there's the duplication mechanism in
place and the second thing is simply the
data redundancy uh i hope this clarifies
a bit
thanks uh there was just also a few
questions on what the a n acronym means
whether it was artificial neural network
or uh
approximately
approximately his neighbors yeah okay
okay i think that is the last of the
questions does anybody else have
anything else to ask marcia one more
from brian how do you deal with
documents which might be about a few
different subjects
is it a composite score of some kind
this is a
great great question and this is on our
roadmap to handle this kind of uh
of challenges because we observe that
it's not that frequent but it may appear
that there are articles
uh that touches multiple different
projects right
so if we go for like a simple ner
solution in this case uh we'll have like
you know
the same information and duplicated many
times like numbers of total square feet
numbers of addresses and so on uh so we
are aware of this challenge we are not
handling it right now but we are about
to handle it and the initial
investigation and initial ideas are
mainly focused about co-reference
resolution and grouping uh the
uh
and grouping the named entities
regarding the
uh
these sub projects that are present in
the article so hopefully maybe next year
i will be able to talk how we dealt with
uh that challenge but this is a really
really uh good point
great thank you very much martian so
we're out of time now somebody asked
about a github link
if you anybody else has any questions
for marchen if you could take it up on
slack that would be great thank you very
much everybody